do you see that as then meaning that the
free energy principle as it's currently
formulated
is incomplete in some manner given
special relativity let's say that or any
relativity says that
time and space must be on some equal
footing and if you're saying that time
has some privileged
position then well position needs to
have a an equally privileged position
right yeah
that question is above my pay grade i
personally don't know you can easily
get um
dynamics or mechanics
out of a longevan formulation
that has time bait into the very core
of it you know at the beginning but just
right now the launch on you can work the
whole way thing uh
the whole um density dynamics up um
and at non-equilibrium steady state you
can write down quite you know
a simple potential function that
describes general relativity um so i
don't think there's no i didn't know
that
okay because when i was looking at some
of your notes i know you call it the
launchman
equation i can never pronounce that so i
always called it the kolmogorov forward
equation for some reason that's easier
for me but whatever the launch man is
that correct launch fan
yeah so that's how i say it anyway yes
okay well let's just say like that for
now
yes right okay so the launch van
equation
it can it can imply newtonian mechanics
i saw that you were showing that in one
of your slides as well as quantum
mechanics
as well as some aspect of thermodynamics
and then i forgot the fourth one but
then i didn't see special relativity or
non-relativistic quantum mechanics
you're saying that you can tweak some of
the parameters to derive general
relativity
yep um and it all rests upon the way
that you configure the
um the um
the the gradient flows that have the
dissipative um
the lender system a dissipative aspect
um
versus the um solenoidal flows
that um characterize more conservative
systems so when we're talking about
special
sorry general relativity for example
excuse me
um we're almost um
considering the limiting case where the
random fluctuations are attenuated by
being averaged away and we're talking
about sort of massive bodies
um moving around so it's just a question
of
of looking at the various functional
forms you would get
out of the solution to the commercial
forward equation
um under the limit that gamma is is
is very very sorry the amplitude the
random fluctuations is very
very small so the gradient flows almost
disappear
um so then it's just a question look at
the functional forms and with a few
nonlinearities here and there you can
you can quite you can quite you can
quite easily uh write down something
that that
the general you know relativity we will
be
quite comfortable with there are some
interesting twists here but
you know if you start putting back the
random fluctuations
into the so general solution um
to um the um the focal plank equation or
the
uh the camogra forward equation
um and sorry just for the people
listening the [ __ ] plank equation and
then the
launch van equation and the kolmogorov
forward equation are all
synonyms yes or the special cases of one
another
yeah well the launchvan equation is is
just the
the underlying uh equation that
describes
the the the flow of the system as a
function of the states
uh but if you've if you know that and
you know the amplitude of any random
fluctuations on that flow
then you can do you can equivalently
write that down as a [ __ ] plank
equation or a car molecular forward
equation
i should also say incidentally you can
also write it down
equivalently in terms of a path integral
formulation you know
all of these could be um thought of as
different ways of just articulating the
same thing
um so but the density dynamics most
transparently inherits from the
you know from the the focal plank or the
commodore
formulation which is explicitly about
how the probabilities
over the states um evolve over time
so one example of that would be this
time independent
scrolling a wave equation um you know
which is
you know one version of a of a vocal
equation
what they have in common is describing
the dynamics
of um of systems um
uh in terms of uh the probability
density over the states
um or if you need quantum mechanics over
the other sort of the
um i would say the wave function of
states
um so at steady state
um if i really need to go to steady
state but certainly
once you've written down um the
the fokker planck equation um and
solved it for uh the flow and then use
the helmholtz decomposition
to split the contributions to flow into
the solenoidal
and gradient flow parts then
that provides sort of a nice way of
looking at limiting cases so
the gradient flow is realized by
the random fluctuations so that you know
for
for people who you're not physicists um
i often use the following analogy that
you know imagine that i placed a drop of
ink
in a cup of water um and
the inc for dissipative systems um
or you know a dissipative ink would
disperse itself throughout the solvent
as a
random molecular uh fluctuations um
cause the ink molecules to diffuse down
concentration
gradients until you had you know a
maximum entropy
dissipated dissolved um
uh sort of equilibrium within the sort
of the heat bath or or the boundaries
supplied
supplied by the glass that's not the
kind of system that we're interested in
that's the 20th century
sort of equilibrium physics what we're
interested in is special kinds of ink
that seems to gather themselves up again
into a little globule
and that gathering up in the context of
sir
you stirring the uh stirring the the
glass of water
um can always be written down in accord
with the
um the helmholtz decomposition into two
kinds of flow
one kind of flow is up concentration
gradients
so it's this is the gradient flow i was
talking about that so the molecules are
gathering themselves
together paradoxically if you like
looking as if they're flowing
towards each other or to the highest
concentration the highest
um probabilities or log probabilities
and it's that
it's that gradient flow that is um
responsible for this self-assembly this
sort of
um um the uh the emergence of this
attracting set
of a small number of states that i i
keep visiting and then the solenoidal
flow
is this sort of circular flow around
um uh around the ice the constant you
know in this instance the concentration
um um uh profile the i
the iso concentration uh lines whereas
the gradient flow is is going to the
you know the maximum concentration or
the maximum probability density
so that's non-equilibrium steady state
crucially
that gradient flow is exactly balancing
the dispersion due to the random
fluctuations
so put that another way the gradient
flow
that keeps things glued together as it
were that keeps things
pointing towards that attracting set
that pullback attractor that
states that have a high non-equilibrium
state
density is exactly offsetting the
dispersive dissipative
effects of the random fluctuations which
means that the random fluctuations
realize the gradient flow
so you have to have random fluctuations
before
you can have at non-equilibrium steady
state
the gradient flow so what would happen
if you took them away well what would
happen is there will be no gradient
flows
and things would just have solenoidal
orbits and then we have
basically lagrangian mechanics we have
you know a mechanics app for describing
large bodies heavenly bodies moons and
earths and the like
all they can do is move around in
circles
so they've just got solenoidal flow
that's because there aren't
all the random fluctuations are averaged
away so they're effectively zero so they
can't realize
the gradient flows so they don't fall
towards each other
you know with you know with a suitable
potential energy
um um that would define the you know
the gradient flows or the form of that
non-equilibrium
uh density on the other hand you could
say well no
i'm more interested in systems um that
are hot and fast
really fast like so quantum fast um
where the solenoidal pick can be ignored
i'm just going to focus in on the
uh on the random fluctuations or the the
impact of those on the density dynamics
and then you can ignore the solenoidal
flow we return
to systems that detail balance and we
can um
write down certain you know all all our
favorite thermodynamic laws
um you know and derive all the integral
fluctuation theorems that underwrite
generalizations
of the of of those laws so i you know
from that perspective classical
mechanics where
general relativity might live for
example um
lives at one end of the spectrum very
large cold
no random fluctuations and then quantum
mechanics lives
um at the other end where it's dominated
by
random fluctuations very fast grading
flows and in the middle
is where we live where we've got both
the
um so we're neither committed to
disorbiting for eternally
um so uh you know
orbiting um some
uh you know some center committed
to a periodic orbit um
for the rest of our lives nor do we
dissipate or behave
you know in a sort of in a quantum way
but we're sort of halfway between
um we're at that that right sort of
scale where
there's lots of solenoidal there's lots
of oscillations that
you know that we we are exposed to
imposed from a larger scale such as
tides
that we generate ourselves such as
oscillations in our hearts and our
physiology and our brains
um but at the same time we do have to
contend with the random fluctuations so
you know we spend a lot of our time
doing our grading flows gathering
ourselves up
planning homeostasis keeping ourselves
in
you know actively keeping ourselves um
within certain bounds within
within that within that attracting set
and this moving up the gradient flow is
this analogous to what schrodinger
talked about when he said that life
resists entropy in some way yeah i think
that's absolutely right um you're asking
us if you didn't know
yeah that's exactly right so you know it
in the presence of these um
for at equilibrium uh for you know
certainly enclosed
systems um that don't have um
um sort of low entropy pullback
attractors
um then you will get the second law you
know
in the usual way where all the random
fluctuations eventually dissipate you
and hence you get dissipative systems
and dissipative
dynamics and yet somehow we we
in our existence we are in existence
proof that that's a violation of that
kind of
behavior um and that's basically where
the free energy principle starts it just
says
there are things out there that have to
be explained
that seem to resist the second law so um
scrutiny
framed it in terms of negative neg
entropy uh that's not
right right uh you know to
frame it in terms of um of resisting
those
that entropic dissipation um by this
gathering up behavior and it is those
gradient flows
that are responsible when you just write
down the
dynamics in terms of the helmholtz
decomposition
for providing that balance between the
dissipative effects of
random fluctuations and the
self-organizing
dynamics that exactly balance those
those dissipative effects to give you
this
this non-equilibrium steady state